il ya de la joie bonjour bonjour les
hirondelles et y'a d'la joie dans le
ciel par dessus de toi y'a d'la joie et
surprend le monsieur jacques un jeu la
cousine d'un ami elle a perdu son mari
s'y jeter sous un train
alors faites moi plaisir prenez là non
ça sur le tableau afin de faire de cette
colocation moment agréable qui est
important de respecter quelques règles
de base c'est l'aspirateur basse piratés
je me tapais tout ménage c'est ça ben si
tu veux bourse écrit mais vous payez pas
de péter après un jeûne est plaint pas
s'il vous plaît
bonjour vous paierez pas non non on fait
quoi oui c'est pas j'habite à vous
connaissez les verts n'ont fait non on
croit connaître les gens sont à la porte
et c'est pour ça qu'on s'est trompé le
faux cul je te le dire en quelle langue
c'est fini 2e du super g a tous été
ridicule soit ça change ça allait de soi
je mets tout le monde là je suis
d'accord avec toi
c'est quoi ce bordel appliquer les plans
éleveurs nous sommes vos amis
en tout cas je trouve que depuis que je
suis là vous allez beaucoup de mes à moi
ses cheveux
bonjour bonjour j'ai encore tout y est
là je te préviens en citer aussi égoïste
que ça ça va pas le faire et chouchou
lille et brûlant qui l'a touché je
l'avais dans mes mains je dis juste
qu'il est vieux je fais attention et
fille du père mais je le finisse un
symbole fort monsieur
[ __ ] il ya un élevage